At Jedi master Ray asks,
if you could meet one character from the star Wars universe and ask them one
question, who would you pick and what would you ask?
I think I would go with Bray, honestly,
just because I want to know if she's happy. I want to know if she's doing okay.
I mean, I would have to go with my favorite character ever. Big stark lighter.
I would ask him how he made such a glorious
mustache. It's something that I just did for the first time. I grew my,
my very first mustache and it was itchy. I didn't really care for it.
I want to know, uh, how he felt about his mustache. Hi, I'm Alex Damon.
And I'm Molly Damon. And this is star Wars support.
At Andy Keach asks,
when did it become bad for Mandalorians to remove their helmets in front of
people? Jango Fett is often without his helmet and in the clone Wars,
you see Mandalorians without them.
This was pretty definitively answered in chapter 11 of the
Mandalorian, where we see Boca tan.
One of those Mandalorians from the clone Wars, she shows up,
she takes her helmet off our Mandalorian. The hero of the show is all a gassed.
Uh, and, and we learned that he has been raised in basically a cult of, uh,
the Mandalorian people.
I assume the children of the watches related to death watch because we saw den
get rescued by members of death, watch in season one.
Kind of an extremist version of Mandalore culture.
Exactly that, uh, so it's okay for most Mandalorians to take their helmets off.
It's just that this one sec, the children of the watch, uh,
demand that you leave your helmet on at Sarah underscore Wolf,
maybe something I shouldn't say out loud, it says quick question.
If I want to start watching star Wars, in which order should I watch the movies?
I'm always a big proponent of just release order. Yeah, we do that.
The reason I think that is because every movie builds on what came before it,
even if they chronologically take place earlier. So yeah,
they're the prequels I think are better viewed having seen the original
trilogy, uh, even small things like rogue.
One kind of has a hint for, uh, the last Jedi,
a small little Easter egg that you can catch. And, uh,
everything just does this little story-building thing. Uh,
if you watch it in release or.
There's really no wrong way or wrong order to watch the star Wars
movies in. But yeah, I think we prefer just release order date.
First time viewer, I would say watch them in the order that they were released.
Stuart web asks, Oh,
now here's another question for the real star Wars nerds are all the characters
that look like humans, the same species that have colonized lots of planets,
or is it a star Trek, parallel evolution thing,
and Han and Leia are different types of aliens. Uh,
I am not familiar.
Enough with star Trek, surprise,
surprise to know exactly what the parallel evolution thing is.
I would guess that humans are the same across the
board, at least in legends, that correspond was their home world.
And then they spread out.
I think it's probably something similar here that humanity probably had a home
world and then colonized other planets.
Yeah. As far as star Wars goes and their species,
a lot of them are just described as human or every once in a while,
for instance, Dryden boss is described as humanoid.
Or yeah. Or in mere human even. Uh,
it definitely sounds like maybe sometimes interbreeding has created near
human species, but for the most part,
I would say that like Han and Leia are the same.
Eric, Michael Garcia says binge watching clone Wars.
And I have an important question. Did obiwan know about Anacon and pad may.
I think 100% there there's that scene where, um,
Anacon has a hollow call with pad Mae and Rex is kind of guarding the door
because he knows what's going on.
And then he's trying to keep [inaudible] out of that room.
And then obiwan later says to Anik and something like,
I hope you at least said hi to Padma for me. Like he.
And there's that moment in revenge of the Sith when OB one basically deduces
that pad May's child is aniguns Ken Collins says,
I have a question for all the star Wars,
legends fans have squadron versus Delta squadron who would win.
Delta squadrons were basically Republic commando units.
They were very elite squads of clone troopers.
We actually see Delta squadron in the clone Wars episode, which is of the mist.
So they are Canon havoc has yet to be mentioned in Canada. As far as I know,
I like Delta squadron more. I had more experience with them.
I'm mostly just choosing them over my own connection with them.
I would prefer that they win. Uh, I really liked the Republic commando game.
Yeah, I'll go with Delta squadron.
I mean, based off the name alone, I want to pick havoc squadron, a house divided
at tail stakes says star Wars lore question.
The Jedi are a religion, right?
Do you have to be forced sensitive to practice the religion?
If someone is born without force sensitivity,
but still adheres to the teachings,
would they be recognized as a non force using Jedi?
Again, we don't really know a whole lot about the history of the Jedi, uh,
in legends, there was a whole thing with the throw your,
and like basically a bunch of people around the galaxy,
like felt the calling of the force in it,
brought them all to this one place where they started, uh, the J dye religion.
And that evolved into the Jedi for Canon.
We don't really know how the first Jedi were on Octo.
We don't know if they were all forced sensitive or if they were just trying to
access whatever they were the forest at that time,
if they knew there was something to their galaxy that they could tap
into it it's possible that they were all just a bunch of dudes that figured it
out.
Yeah. There's that mosaic on Octo of what they called the prime
Jedi. But I think that's more of an example of what a prime Jedi is
perfectly balanced, yin and yang.
There is something called the church of the force,
Laura San Teka and the force awakens was a member of that.
So there are definitely people who believe in the force,
but might not be able to touch it in the same way that the Jedi do.
I would guess that at least the Jedi of the prequel era would not recognize
anyone that couldn't use the forest. They are very strict, rule-based rigid.
So I don't think that they would be like, Oh, well, you can't use the forest,
but you still want to be one of us, like, come on it. And I don't,
I don't see them trying to nurture anyone in that.
Yeah. I don't think they would be considered Jedi in that case.
The first person that came to my mind was Maz Kanata it seems like she
has some connection to the forest, but she wouldn't consider herself a Jedi.
Every living being does have some connection to the forest.
It's like whether or not you tap into that.
Well, I personally believe that anyone in the star Wars galaxy has the
capability to use the force.
They just need to be taught how, I mean,
Luke went from not knowing what it was to blowing up the death star in like a
day. I think that it's on purpose that in the prequel era,
we see the Jedi like testing Atkins blood to be like, well,
what's his medical Orien count like, and is it worth it to bring him in?
And I actually think that is like a fault of the Jedi is that they're testing
potential instead of like passion, if someone is like,
I want to become a Jedi and it's like, I want to learn this stuff.
And they're like, well, we don't think it's worth the time to train you.
I kind of think that's what the pre-qual era Jedi,
what George was trying to say with them at Tavenner's CD says it's time to bring
back philosophy Friday with a star Wars twist answer.
The question was Luke Skywalker, correct?
In his assessment of the Jedi during the last Jedi are the Jedi fundamentally
flawed and how they approached the force.
His first sort of lesson that he gives to Ray in
the last Jedi is that the forest does not belong to the Jedi.
And he talks about how flawed they were in their teachings
of, yeah, I think that was pretty spot on.
I think that the Jedi of the prequel era have lost their way.
I absolutely think that that was George Lucas's intent in the prequel trilogy.
They were very different from the way many of us imagine them to be when we just
saw the original trilogy.
And then I think he doubled down on that when you get into the clone Wars series
at Rebecca, Brinker's says, quick question for star Wars, fans,
think Vader ever fell asleep at a meeting. This should have been an email.
I mean, he's got the helmet on. So who would know? Yes.
I want that to be true very badly. Now.
It would depend on his breathing whether or not people would notice,
I guess.
Snoring sounds like with that helmet on.
I don't know. Yeah.
I guess if he maybe just started to slump over people would be like,
Hey Vader.
I'm awake.
Trying to think of, of a, an excuse he could give in a situation like this.
Like, Oh, I had a firmware update at rabid.
Solar has a question for any star Wars nerds. That would be us. Uh,
what does an extremely expensive slash precious material in the galaxy far,
far away that would be equivalent to gold or diamonds to us Khyber
best car.
Those were the first two that popped into my mind.
I think best scar is pretty close because it seems like everyone
Mondo comes across and they realize what his outfit is made out of.
They want to immediately steal it because it's worth a lot of money.
Best scar is what Mandalorian armor is made out of. Uh,
it's very durable.
It's nearly blaster proof.
The only thing we've really seen truly destroy best car armor is a mud
horn so far. Uh, but yeah,
it's a very precious metal, a rare metal that Mandalorian armor is made out of,
but also it can be used as currency Kyber crystals are the crystals that
power a jeopardize lightsaber. They were also used to power.
The death star is super laser. They are called living crystals.
They have a connection to the force.
They would call out to Jedi and that's how they would find their lightsaber.
Crystal.
I would guess that maybe Kyber crystals are even more rare with the Jedi,
not around. I mean, even when the Jedi were around,
like lightsabers on the black market were highly prized. So yeah,
I think you hit the nail on the head with both of those.
I know that there are things, uh,
the comics recently brought back in like Ruby sapphires and the same
precious gemstones that we have in the real world exist out there. But I mean,
Kyber crystals and best scar still seem to be more rare and valuable
general clinker says sometimes before death,
the separatists battle droids of the star Wars prequels yell. Oh my God.
So that begs the question who introduced them to religion,
where they programmed with religious beliefs and who is the joy to God. Well,
I do think that they have some sort of belief system.
I mean, it might just be something they say, but three PO says, thank the maker.
Yeah.
I was going to bring up the idea of the maker and I assume that's just who
created them is, is three PO thanking an akin. In that sense.
It might just be kind of a thing that they say like,
thank the person that gave me life,
but there is definitely an argument to be had that droids are sentient.
I mean, L three, three seven, I think proves that. So I,
I don't know that the battle droids we're programmed to
have religion,
but I do think that it's possible for them to just develop it on their own
without a constant memory wise.
At ITU studio says very important question from ad blockbuster pod.
Is this the first sweater in star Wars?
Well, I mean, everyone kind of went nuts for Ben solos,
a good boy sweater and the rise of Skywalker. Very good boy. Uh,
this might be the first fishermen sweater though.
Like the first cable knit sweater, I'd say yeah.
Off the top of my head. I can't think of anyone on Hoth wearing one. Uh, that,
that feels like the place. You'd see. One Galen air.
So kind of has one on law mew.
Did they wear them in the holiday special though? The original one?
Uh, no, but you, you are right about the, the new Lego one Vader,
whereas a Christmas sweater.
Yeah. It's a Lego sweater, but it's still, it's still meant to be a sweater.
My question with this Mon calamari sweater, man though,
how does he get it on and off without stretching the neck hole
out and not to mention their arms, their forearms are huge.
So how do you get like your sleeves on? They would rip that sweater apart.
Maybe in the back is just covered in buttons and it's,
they just have to button it up front to back.
Hector Roman says Boca tan has been alive since the first six movies and she
still looks good question. How old is she?
Bo Catan is the sister of Duchess sateen.
Kreis who used to be in charge of all of Mandalore. She ruled Mandalore space.
She was kind of a controversial leader because she was trying to make
Mandalorians, uh, more pacifist.
They used to be hardcore conquers and very aggressive, violent people.
And she was trying to help her people evolve beyond that.
Boca tan was a member of a group called death, watch that opposed the pacifism.
Uh, so Boca tan was actually a Mandalorian terrorist for a while, but, uh,
she has since kind of come around,
she tried to save her sister's life and failed.
And since then has been fighting. What I would say is the good fight.
I think there's still some darkness in her. Uh,
and I hope the series continues to explore that my best guess is 50
55.
I would say that she could be like 20 at the very youngest in the clone
Wars.
And then you're adding about 30 years onto that for the time of the Mandalorian.
We discussed this a little bit, um,
after seeing this amazing episode of the Mandalorian and I decided
that because Mandalorians were helmets most of the time,
she just hadn't, hasn't gotten a lot of sun damage. So yeah, she looks great.
John Carl says not a critique,
but a genuine question prior to the Ray trilogy was astral projection ever
established in star Wars, either in Canon or legends.
I can't remember seeing it before this trilogy for the life of me.
This book, the Jedi path is technically a legends book,
but page one 32 talks about a power called doppelganger,
which is exactly what Luke does.
And the last Jedi also,
you can do it in one of the old dark forces games where you play marriage aid.
Uh,
you could make a doppelganger to confuse your enemies and like basically just
have, uh, another copy of you running around fighting.
Skier says star Wars question.
Why do they call it an X wing when the end universe standard language,
the letter for X looks like a triangle.
So yes, our rubbish is the most prominent alphabet within star Wars.
Uh, but it's not the only alphabet there exists a,
I think it's called the high galactic alphabet and that is our own.
So there is an a, a, B, a C and an X in star Wars.
And I guess the, the people that make those ships just preferred that alphabet.
Hayes Brown has a question.
How does being strong in the forest run and families, if Jedi in theory,
the most in tune aren't allowed to have family.
I think that the Skywalker blood was kind of a specialty.
That's definitely how it started. It was a special case. The chosen one. Yeah.
He was literally like akin was born of the force. And it seems like, yeah,
any offspring he had and his line would also just be very strong
in the force,
but that is not like a tried and true definite yes.
Every Jedi is going to have a force sensitive child.
If you go back to some legend stuff,
the older public era Revon and [inaudible], uh,
they were two very powerful Jedi and they did have
some children who were forced sensitive. But if you go down the line,
their descendants sateen had a son Theron and he was not forced
sensitive at all.
So it's not like a given that a two Jedi or one Jedi are
going to have force sensitive children.
What a bummer that would be to be the only non for sensitive sibling.
Oh, he definitely had like a complex about it.
Yeah. Alexander yard says, good morning.
Here's the question for my star Wars geeks.
What's a buck hand was Han solo holding when he won the Falcon from Lando.
They didn't reveal that. And so low, I'm going to go idiots array.
That's that's the hardest hand to get.
I mean, it's gotta be either that or fulsome buck.
Those are the two big winning hands, correct.
Idiots array is unbeatable full SubAQUA is the one that Lando was
probably trying to go for us and see was trying,
he wanted that little green Psylocke.
Yeah. I'm going to assume it was full Slovak,
but I think there's also different versions of that you can play. There are.
Yes. And even they were said to be playing, uh,
the Numidian prime rules, uh, while they were there.
And yet Hahn's gold dice supposed to be,
this is something I was hoping to see because the visual dictionary say that his
gold dice were used for him to win the millennium Falcon and a version of the
game called Kirlian spike. But we didn't see that happen.
So that probably isn't true that visual dictionary bit got overwritten,
but he never revealed his hand. So we don't know.
At Dr. Seekers says,
here's the real question does bought to celebrate Christmas because I'd love to
see how black Spire does the holidays. That's a good question. I, you know,
with all the actual spires,
I think it would be neat to have all those decorated with lights.
And I bet they celebrate life. Day.
Day is the star Wars equivalent of the holidays,
Christmas or whatever you want to call it.
And it's traditionally a Wookie celebration,
a them just celebrating life on their home world of Cacique,
but it seems like it has spread throughout the galaxy a little bit more. Uh,
and it's usually held on November 17th and life day comes from
the notorious original 1978 star Wars holiday
special, uh,
that George Lucas has since described as wishing he could hunt down every copy
and destroy it with a hammer. It's a rough watch, frankly.
Yes, it's a little trippy. Um, but they did recently revise it, uh,
and made a Lego holiday special, uh,
that just came out a couple of days ago actually. And it's,
it was just a ball of fun if we're talking strictly the bot too,
that we see at Galaxy's edge and Disneyland and Disney world,
I have to imagine they're going to decorate it during the holidays.
Maybe we'd see Chewy's family. They're just walking around the park, but yeah,
I have to imagine bot to celebrates life day or some form of
it. Thank you all so much for your star Wars questions. This.
Has been star Wars support.